have i not gone live
i don't know what the [ __ ] is going on
why do i have to press so many buttons
um
there's start stop streaming and there's
end broadcast so i don't know which one
is which
but uh yeah i mean it's good to finally
take a break and also it's good because
i got it from the highest authority i
got it from people that i really respect
who told me to
that i don't have to keep doing shitty
open mics so i think that's a great
uh if i'm not if that's if i needed a
sign from anyone it's those people that
i've respected and that i got into
comedy for joe rogan tony hinchcliffe
brian redband so it's just great that uh
these people care about me enough to
tell me what to do and that i
uh
you know that they are helping me so
that's cool
um
so yeah i mean i'm gonna stop doing
shitty open mics now
because the i couldn't hear it from a
higher authority and even if god himself
came down and told me to stop doing open
mics
i wouldn't uh be taking it as seriously
as if tony hinchcliffe and joe rogan
told me
so that's pretty cool
so i think i just started going live i
think i know i don't know
oh my god nobody heard what i said
before okay
uh so
here's a rundown i'm not high i'm not
tired i'm not
uh what was the third one high tired
uh
[ __ ]
i forget god damn i did all this before
and then i forgot to press go live or
whatever
um
i'm not high i'm not tired my eyes are
open that was that was the third thing
i'm in a new apartment i'm in curtis's
apartment um
i i have curtis's apartment i have
access to curtis's apartment because
he's away for christmas he's visiting
family i think
so he gave me the keys to his place and
i'm looking after his dog
so this is his kitchen that i'm
streaming from hopefully he doesn't mind
um
he is gonna be the new general manager
or some in some sort of official cap
capacity at the club that uh is opening
up in
austin texas so
you know stay tuned for that
it's pretty cool thing
um
and uh yeah now
i i'm looking after his dog so hopefully
he'll book me a lot
i will be trying to fix the audio at on
the dating show
it's not really my audio it's really the
creek in the caves audio and their sound
board that they have to get
fixed there's only so much i can do from
my end i don't know how to work their
system if they don't fix their system
then i don't know how to do it
[Music]
it's not cody it's uh
[ __ ]
now you messed me up
curtis curtis not from the yellow rose
um
yeah
let's go brandon
hilarious
i think that uh
it's good i have now three homes that i
have access to
one is my van some people would say
that's not really a home but i can sleep
in it so i have access to that then i
have curtis as a part a house that i'm
in and then i have rachel's apartment
i have three places i can stay i'm well
saturated
thomas in terms of domiciles
um
do you think aliens have a sense of
humor yes i think it's natural i think
it's a part of our consciousness i think
it's a way to find humor and fun in
logic
is austin expensive to live not that
expensive the best advice joe or tony
has given you about stand up joe and
tony have recently told me to stop doing
shitty open mics and r.a shafir has also
said that that was good advice that he
got so i'm gonna start doing that i'm
gonna start not i'm gonna start stopping
going to shitty open mics
um
so that's pretty cool i couldn't have
heard it from a higher authority people
i actually and love
uh truly love and respect
so i mean if uh if they tell me anything
i'm gonna do it
uh
so it's like pretty cool that they're
giving me advice and i'm excited to see
how my stand-up changes now that i
stopped doing shitty open mics
um
the thing about shitty open mics is that
the people at the shitty open mics are
depressed and insecure and vicious and
they just want to see you fail or be
transgressive
and they want you to see a change for
whatever they have in mind to make
themselves feel better and they prevent
you from being your the best version of
yourself they want to just see you
kowtow to whatever the energy of the
room is
so
it's
not good to do too many shitty open mics
uh because then you don't become your
own person you just become whatever the
room needs and then you can't uh
transcend and be
uh
greater than the shitty room that you're
in
so i'm going to stop doing the uh shitty
open mics
um
yeah i mean i'm excited to stop doing
them
um
should be fun
and shitty open mics uh yeah they make
you lose confidence in yourself
but soup
favorite meal to make
um probably ribs i got some ribs right
now i might show you because they're
right there what's the worst emergency
poop experience you've ever had in a van
i was at it was at night at the near the
creek in the cave in new york city long
island city it's a neighborhood in
queens that's right next to manhattan i
tell people i used to live in long
island city and they're like oh that's
not really new york [ __ ] it's closer to
new york city than you've ever been
long island city is like right by
manhattan you couldn't get closer to
manhattan it's just the name of the
neighborhood is long island city they
think it's long island they think it's
on on long island which it is but it's
very very close to manhattan so i was in
uh creek in the cave in the van
um
so then i was in the van and then i had
to take a [ __ ] and so i went outside and
i went to an empty parking lot that's
right next to the creek and i laid down
some plastic
and i took a [ __ ] in the middle of like
five am
hopefully no one saw me i took a [ __ ]
out there and then flies were instantly
on top of it
i picked it up like it was dog [ __ ] in a
plastic bag and threw it away but i
really had to go and i was looking
around and then i took a [ __ ] in the
parking lot
uh outside the van which is very very
safe
um
if joe says jump do it
exactly
he is uh he has outsized power
it's crazy and how amazingly competent
he is so if he says something that i'll
probably listen
um and i think it's great like they told
me
uh what to do and i'm excited to follow
their orders because you know
individual autonomy is good but also
listening to people who have experience
and done it before is good too
and i'm not that
entitled i don't think that just doing
everything the way that i want to do it
is the best thing in the world i love
listening to other people
i just choose
who to listen to and
i choose joe rogan and tony hinchcliffe
like most people have
most people don't have a personal
relationship with them though
so
yeah now that i do
uh there's no re no way that i wouldn't
listen to them
um
have
you ever posted jokes on reddit if so
what was your best one probably my
communist one it's the third highest
post on our stand-up comedy check it out
everyone can be an a-hole but not
everyone can be funny
i mean some people can't be a-holes like
perpetually nice people
um but yeah being funny is hard
um
do you think elias know
have you ever made a meme i have made a
meme do you have water in the van still
no van to it i know i need to do a van
tour it's just a pain in the ass i'll do
it soon
um
huns
uh how long you been in the game
the game of life i've been in 32 years
the game of comedy eight years the game
of living in austin nine months
the game of
being on kill tony five months
it's just been a great time i've been
doing a lot of stuff recently this move
to austin has really been beneficial
i was
uh in la for three months and then in
november
i saw the numbers going up or october i
saw the numbers going up and covid
numbers spiking so i was like
i bounced i moved to the middle of the
forest and i mean the desert
let me turn this down so i don't look so
[ __ ] white
i moved to the middle of the desert uh
started living
there um
and uh that's great uh
lived there for four months then went to
yuma arizona in january
watch the january 6th insurrection from
there
uh
i guess it wasn't four months like two
months three months
and then after you my started living in
the desert more so maybe four months
total in march i moved
to
uh
to austin so from november
to
march
that's about four months plus a month
in yuma arizona living with my friend
rebecca
so i did i hung out with
rebecca for a month in her little casita
so
yeah i mean it was pretty cool
what was the question
how many years
in the game
uh yeah so
yeah i mean uh
it was pretty crazy living in the van
doing crazy [ __ ] in there uh four months
then i
yeah i don't know what i was talking
about
this is just what i sound like
uh if you want to watch blue's clues and
listen to someone oh hi guys then you
can watch that
uh riley uh i would love to do a podcast
with riley again and he just
uh he just uh doesn't uh i don't know it
takes a lot of effort for me to get him
to do anything
uh
you know do you feel grounded i guess i
do feel grounded
uh still talking to paige no i'm not
talking to her i don't think she's a
very nice person
you ever go poop hunt poon hunting with
dalia and callum
yeah
that's such an old school
that's like how people in the 90s
thought about [ __ ] hey man you just
gotta go out and get it yeah [ __ ] yeah
it's like mountain dew
they're like treating [ __ ] like it's
[ __ ]
uh nickelodeon show
just
just meth out it was very meth energy in
the 90s
uh so i don't believe in that i believe
in the sex being a beautiful organic
beautiful thing
and um
yeah i mean i think that it's more like
the 70s and the hippies
kind of stuff
where'd the dog go hopefully the dog's
not
doing something crazy
um
asian lives matter
uh but yeah i mean uh i just think that
they're a victim of the culture that
they were in but i hope that they're
better now and i think that they're very
cool guys in other ways so i'm sure that
they can figure out the sex part of
their life
uh janice redband's girlfriend is very
beautiful and nice and um
that's all i'll tell you about that
because uh you shouldn't think about
other people's girlfriends too much
uh is the van a full conversion i mean
it's pretty full to me
it's got everything i want i really need
to do a van tour i'll do it tomorrow
i'll do it by myself if i have to i'll
figure it out
no lives matter again
how do i shower gyms
i'm not lined up to go on joe rogan's
podcast but i'm ready at a minute's
notice i'll drop everything to go on it
obviously
i'd probably get like 20 000 more
followers at least
do you enjoy watching adult movies oh do
i i love tickling i love forced orgasm
porn i love
japanese bondage porn i love i love
japanese porn japanese people make
really good porn the only thing is they
have to blur out the vagina which i'm
not a fan of
but the japanese are really good at
being creepy
and like
they take real world situations and then
they add sex to it i feel like american
porn is just like
over produced and like
oh we're having sex we're really good at
this we're pouring stars
and in japan there's just like people
that are [ __ ]
uh
and i think like
american porn is like they try to go
extreme
a lot of it is like [ __ ] that white
dudes do to each other
during sleepovers and it's just like
trying to see what the dirtiest thing
you can do to someone is and i'm not
really
that big a fan of that kind of uh
pornography or sex i would rather
uh you know
slowly violate people's boundaries
in a consensual way of course with
someone who enjoys having their
boundaries
stepped upon by the ways that they uh
they enjoy it
but it's like a massage japanese massage
porn they're in a massage and then
slowly they get them horny and then they
start
finger blasting them so it's just cool
uh would you really
i don't
yeah i don't have to read all the
comments
that you
said you ever does he ever join
how the [ __ ] are you guys spelling this
this is like french where they have
decoyed with the d apostrophe accord
it's like they combine you got martin
mantis
stillman
just combined all of his words together
i like a blurry gash says autism powers
you should know you're autistic too
i don't want to see the
imperfection
of uh
the human vagina
i love it when
women get vagina surgery to make their
vaginas look more like [ __ ] i don't
know like a goddamn
open wound
no i'm just kidding obviously that's
disgusting i don't think you should get
vagina surgery i think you should
instead get a boyfriend who can learn
how to love your disgusting vagina
because a lot of people can love a lot
of disgusting vaginas you just gotta
find a guy that's willing to do that for
your
particular kind of vagina and some guy
might even really love all the flaps so
i don't i don't think you should get
vaginal surgery like all men have penile
surgery
because they want it to look a certain
way i love the ufc i've been watching
the ufc for a while i've also
participated in the sport of brazilian
jiu jitsu
any ufo sightings nope
uh there are weird lights the military
is always there bombing [ __ ]
it's crazy i drove through a military
bombing site they're like don't go off
the road or will you have the right to
bomb you so that's pretty crazy
how are you even seeing right now it's
because my eyes are pointed downwards so
the camera's a little high
so if i'm looking right at you this is
how big my eyes are when i'm reading the
chat so maybe this can give you a sense
of how high the camera is
what's your thoughts on pegging i think
pegging is just like some uh
white boy at a sleepover thing they just
want to try a lot of [ __ ] it was a few
inches higher you look less high well i
uh i mean is that important you guys
need me to be sexy to listen to me
ramble about how i love japanese porn
um let me see how high i can get it
wow is that better
uh we love the mud flaps
i mean pegging is nice i guess if you
find the right woman to do it because
it's you don't always want to be the one
[ __ ]
i mean in a truly genderless society
we'd be doing both and there's like a
beauty in both human experiences
in terms of [ __ ] and
getting [ __ ] and i don't think that uh
one person should uh
only do one thing but i don't think that
people in our society are immature
enough to pug peg
pug peg dang me
i don't trust them
enough to stick my dick in them for most
of the time i don't think that i want
them inside me i don't think that they
have the uh
intellectual or emotional intelligence
to treat me right in a pecking situation
um
but i think that if i was in a truly
like utopian society
i would uh love to get pegged sometimes
but i just don't uh i don't think that
this society that i'm a part of is
worthy of pegging me
i am a goddamn
roman senator after all
i guess i'm just a [ __ ] arrogant
little [ __ ] who thinks i'm better than
getting anally stimulated
uh but yeah i mean uh i i hope to one
day find a woman
who is willing to uh
[ __ ] me in the [ __ ]
and
and uh yeah
and uh maybe then uh yeah then i could
feel and then she wouldn't she couldn't
be like weird about it like oh yeah i
pegged him now i own you
uh some very harmful ideas about sex
that people hold subconsciously that i
wouldn't want to be a part of but
yeah i mean i'd love to find uh
someone who loves to peg me
i can't do stand up in korean mostly
because i haven't tried but i would love
to try
and i hope to do it one day because i
love koreans and i love speaking korean
if you didn't live in austin where would
you choose to live probably los
angeles because i would be trying to do
comedy but if i wasn't trying to do
comedy maybe denver maybe in the middle
of the desert
um
yeah
i think living in the middle of the
desert is
cool um
[Music]
peggy
i'm getting pegged by peggy
uh
ever been with asian women i've been
with multiple asian women but not at the
same time i met one girl on tinder who
we had an informal thing with and i
would come over every now and then and
we'd have sexual intercourse and she was
not that attractive she looked like a
goblin or like a frog she had no chin
and she was kind of wide
um and then i was late to go [ __ ] her
one day and she was like i can't do this
i feel disrespected because you're late
and i just can't
let myself feel like this anymore
and honestly i thought that was a very
mature thing to say on her part but also
i thought it was kind of [ __ ] up that
she thought that me being late was a
sign of disrespect
i think that
it's kind of [ __ ] up
that
everyone is like in this time thing
like because we go to school and we go
to work we think that uh showing up on
time is this very important thing but if
you go to spain or brazil
they have a very more loose er
definition of time and they're like
you're supposed to be here at 6 00 p.m
if you're not here at 6 p.m then i don't
know what to do with myself i have no
other life to live besides waiting on
other people to show up and if i can
rely on you like a machine then i don't
want to be with you
but i mean even though she thought that
way which i disagree with i thought that
she handled it very maturely and just
cut me out of her life without any drama
then i just faded into the night
so that was a pretty painless breakup
um
so that was an asian woman uh but yeah i
hate this time thing because i live in a
van i do comedy i show up on time for
the comedy show but if it's just to like
hang out with a friend and i show up at
seven instead of six
and you're just at home doing nothing
anyways it's not like we're supposed to
meet at like seven hours away and you
drove all that way or something
uh or you're sitting in a restaurant for
an hour by yourself if it's just like
you were just gonna be home anyways and
i show up an hour late then do something
else do the dishes do your laundry uh
write a little bit um
so
um
so yeah i mean uh i uh i just don't uh
like if if someone is late when i'm
hanging out and i have other things to
do then i'll do that like i have plenty
of stuff i could be doing so i'm never
mad if someone's late unless like i
drove somewhere else to be there and i
don't have access to the things that i
could do but everyone has a phone now
and whatever you can do anything
anywhere so i don't know i don't think
that being late is that big of a deal
uh
maybe hit them up and let them know just
like a text or something hey i opened
for joe rogan now don't you feel bad
that you wanted to stop [ __ ] me i
honestly don't feel the need to do that
i don't want to invite that kind of
negative energy in my life um
i don't want to start texting exes or
people who rejected me on tinder to be
like you done [ __ ] up [ __ ]
because then uh
you know it's just like i'd rather live
in a positive area in my life where
i just ignore them and do whatever the
[ __ ] i want to do because if i don't
know it's just like
if i do that then they're gonna respond
and then i'm gonna have to respond back
and it's gonna be like a whole thing and
it's just going to ruin my day i'd
rather just do reddit and just yell at
people on reddit and
argue with them and then just leave them
because i don't even know them the if
they're people that i actually know they
have the potential to hurt me and like
if they don't hurt me then other people
seeing that are like wait i have some
dirt on this [ __ ] let me [ __ ]
him up
uh i just don't want to open up that
kind of negativity
uh that's small pp energy anyway small
pb i have a small pp and you
disrespected me in the past and now i
will take revenge on you
that's uh
my uh whatever
my reddit is hans kim comedy i also have
a secret hidden reddit that's not that
secret not that hidden
but i don't want
my comment history to be going out there
so i'm not going to tell you my actual
reddit but i post with hans kim comedy
i have climbed my sister's really into
climbing and her husband's really into
climbing so i've climbed with them
i love a little climby climbing sash but
i wouldn't say i'm good i've done it
before
thoughts on last week's
sir let's see who fought on last week's
ooh fsa
ufc is a combat sport it's the ultimate
combat sport in my opinion because it is
full of
actual things that would work in the
real world
um i think that
before the ufc came around it was all
mysterious is like the way we think
about religion ooh
this fighting camp is the way to go this
is they know the tiger heart technique
and it's all about convincing people
more than actually being good at
fighting and then
ufc actually made it a sport and was
like no this is what you have to do if
you want to
beat the [ __ ] out of someone and murder
them
um
so yeah i mean uh
i think the ufc was great it's science
it's progress it's the future instead of
just thinking about fighting we can
actually fight
and if we're doing boxing anyways why
not do actual fighting
uh but yeah i mean i love the ufc i
think it's the future of the sports
um
what's your favorite race probably
hispanics because they're brown they're
the perfect color
and uh they're sexy
and uh yeah i mean they just have very
good proportions
[Music]
if 2x minus 4 equals y and 3y plus 2
equals 4x solve for x
okay
um
so that's just divided by two
minus four equals y three over two
well plus one minus four three over two
minus three
equals y
so then
minus 3 equals y so then
minus 3 over 2
negative 1 over 2
y
equals negative
uh
3
so i would say that it is
6
y equals six
and if y equals six
then x equals five
five
four six
eighteen plus two
is 20 yeah i did it y equals 6 x equals
5 i think
was the answer
so
2x minus 4 equals y and 3y plus 2 equals
4x i just did it in my head no pen and
paper necessary because i'm asian and
this [ __ ] i probably am really rusty
like if some kid that's actually
studying
high school algebra was watching this he
could probably do it way faster in his
head but hey it's pretty good for not
having done it in 10 years
that's pretty oh i did like tutor
s.a.t and i had to do this [ __ ] but x
equals 5 and y equals 6.
yeah if you don't want to ruin the
stream don't show asian people math
equations
18
yeah i [ __ ] did it
dude [ __ ] awesome 2x minus 4 equals y
and 3y plus 2 equals 4x the answer is x
equals 5 and y equals six if there's two
equations and two variables you can
solve it
um
i just got
in
to asian doing math
is this a bit
uh that's always correct great cuddy
steffik
um
let's go brandon
i got it a couple weeks ago and i can't
still
dude have you got covered yet i did have
coved
i had kovid i can't really tell you when
but
i got over it pretty quick i'm
vaccinated i got vaccinated in like uh
april as my second dose and then i got
covered in like
pretty pretty soon after that and uh you
know it wasn't too bad i was sick for
two days and it felt terrible
uh but i got over it pretty quick and i
think it's because of the vaccine
um
do you think the ufc pays fighter less
money because they look
they took a loan through the mafia
yeah the mafia is called dana white who
hope i hope i don't meet now because i
said that publicly but i mean it's like
not his fault this is just the way that
our economy is structured if you can
take all the money you do and if you
can't exploit people you do
and uh this he's just playing the game
the way it's written and uh he loves it
and i'm not saying he's blameless but i
mean you can't really blame him when you
have the same thing happening in walmart
when you have the same thing happening
in every company in america
the top guy takes everything and the
people who actually do the work and risk
their body
get paid nothing i think that's unjust i
think that's horrible
and i think the fighters need to get
health insurance covered
especially because that's the job is to
get hurt
and then you're going to have way better
fights you're going to have way better
fighters people who are actually
dedicating themselves full time don't
have to live with their mom and work a
waiter job to fight and if that happens
then you're going to get a better
product but you're not going to get that
short-term profit right away
if you get from milking these fighters
and treating them like cattle
so you know until we have a a society
that
treasures long-term thinking and honors
uh respecting people and not treating
people like [ __ ]
this is uh the ufc that we're gonna have
and
the people at the top conor mcgregor
dana white
fertitta when he owned it they're gonna
make all the money and then everyone
else is going to be [ __ ] even though
they're actually doing the work
so i
think that's horrible yeah i like to
milk fighters who doesn't love to milk a
fighter imagine how powerful you feel if
you can exploit and cheat a ufc fighter
and be like i take money from the
toughest men in the world
that's [ __ ] that's [ __ ] baller
[ __ ] right there most people are
exploiting pencil neck geeks who sit in
offices i exploit the toughest men in
the world
that is uh
that's that's so [ __ ]
but if you're gonna be a
capitalist don't be a [ __ ]
go try to cheat people who can kick your
ass
um
[Music]
you ever steve will do it yeah my friend
riley introduced me to this guy who
became rich because he did a bunch of
crazy [ __ ] on youtube obviously that's
not a stable solution for everyone we
can't all just shove chopsticks up our
nose and
make an economy based on watching each
other fart on each other but i'm glad
that he could do it
i just don't think that's a sign that
our system works but i'm i'm amused by
it obviously
um
i like living with my mom there's
nothing wrong with living with your mom
it's just like if you're a ufc fighter
maybe you should have the option to not
do that
any milk fighters
says
exploiting intellectual intellect is
harder than
those ufc guys i think most of them
never seen a contract yeah it is easier
to exploit uh
illiterate
uh fist bangers but this the risks are
higher if you if you get caught
what's your biggest flaw in your comedic
character i would say my awkwardness
which is like a good thing
but it's also a bad thing because my
awkwardness is uh
there's a low ceiling like i can get
funny fast by being awkward but then i
plateau
so i would say uh maybe i would
need to learn how to not be so awkward
but then people like emo phillips and
mitch hedberg found a way to be awkward
their whole lives it's just you gotta
find the truth in your awkwardness and
not just doing it out of ego
but out of uh actual
uh whatever
actual authenticity you're awkward
because that's who you are how about
recording street fights put the video on
the internet and give the fighters the
full revenue
um that's fine uh to make your own
little ufc but the structure already
exists you want to make a whole new
thing or do you want to just improve the
thing that already exists
i mean depends on how difficult they're
gonna make it but yeah i mean that's a
good option to create another ufc
although they're gonna make it hard
because they have a monopoly and they
can buy out all your fighters
and they can
say if you give air time to this
fighting league then you can't show ufc
highlights so they can
uh make the market not a free market
if you have a monopoly and you have
power yeah i think you can put that
comedically well into sketches give it a
shot you're funny what
put one into a sketch
um
it could be that you're awkward but you
think you're totally confident something
like that ufc sans ufc buffer pegging
pegging championships there is actually
a great pornography that i love to
consume called ultimate
surrender where
people try to [ __ ] each other
in a arrest on a wrestling mat and
sometimes they do girl girl sometimes i
do girl guy
and i love all of you this is not a
green screen i'm in uh curtis's
apartment this is curtis's apartment
uh he has a gym that i need to utilize
so my arms don't look so [ __ ] skinny
i'm not in my car anymore i have access
to three houses i have my van i have
rachel's apartment and now i have
curtis's
i have curtis's uh
house
and his doggy
um
refrain from asking false leading
questions to our great leader hans kim
cody steffik uh
is uh treating me like i'm kim jong-un
and i kind of like it it's kind of
turning me on
do you play osrs no don't stop making
out with random women regret is worse
than lupus lupus you don't get lupus
from kissing i think lupus is a genetic
thing it's like an autoimmune thing
uh i think a lot of women get it because
they have to have a strong immune system
because they create a little baby inside
them so they need to be able to fight
off any infections and bacteria so their
body gets really good at attacking [ __ ]
and then it's
it starts attacking itself
do you prefer house survey on i prefer
house believe it or not a house is like
a van except larger more stable
uh and it isn't on the street it's off
the street the only reason i live in a
van is because i live uh freely in a van
i don't have to pay money the economics
is the only reason i don't love diesel i
don't want the smell of tarmac or
concrete i love the freedom
but uh if we lived in a society that
provided housing and uh
food to people then i wouldn't have to
do that
um so let me
take a gander at the
uff from last whatever
uh there's my tiny whatever
charles oliveira versus dustin poirier i
remember watching this fight i thought
dust emporia was going to win i thought
he was doing good
i think charles oliveira
was better
obviously because he won i forget how
the fight went down but i think what
happened was
i don't i don't remember
i don't want to say anything because i
don't [ __ ] remember
um but i thought one was a better
grappler and one was a better striker
and then they got into grappling
exchanges and this grappler one or
something but i don't know i'm not sure
maybe i'm thinking of another fight
juliana pena
defeats amanda nunes to become the woman
bantamweight
uh
champion
uh i thought amanda nunes was too cocky
obviously she thought that uh she would
just steamroll her like she does every
woman
uh
because they can't
withstand the power but juliana pena she
got dropped a couple times in the first
round
and she just was like
i'm still here i'm not quitting i'm just
gonna take these i signed up for this i
knew what i was getting into keep at it
keep punching me really hard
i uh let's see how many of these i can
take and amanda nunes was like [ __ ] this
is too much work i thought this would be
easier why isn't she just giving up like
everyone else and then she was like oh
god i have to do this for five rounds
and i think she got discouraged and like
she got tired
and i think it was a mental thing
obviously she's a very fit person
but i mean you can't even fight like two
rounds in the ufc i think she definitely
could she was just like i think she
gassed herself i think she
she got too confident and juliana pena
was just there for her
to be
weak and uh
uh you know give up and relent
she was just there when that happened
and she didn't fault her she
took it and she exploited her mental
weaknesses and she won and i think
that's what makes the ufc so great
is that you can see these things happen
in real time and you can see people who
are unbeatable get beat
because
we all have human minds and we all know
the pitfalls of the human mind and we
can see it play out in real time we've
all been weak we've all faltered
and
now we see that happen in someone else
and we know roughly what that's like
although not to the degree that they're
doing it they're doing it at the highest
level
so it's just good to see uh struggles
that we all go through exaggerated
through the ufc it's good to see someone
win
against tremendous odds
um it's good to see someone uh be
competent and be
proficient in what they do and
finish off a person that was thought to
be unbeatable
and uh to not uh not falter and not give
up and not quit
uh so you see both you see the
the person give up and then another
person not give up
the ryan hall sean o'malley typical sean
o'malley
defeated uh
i don't know raul lee and ro rowley and
paiva
as a typical mismatch sean o'malley was
way too fast
uh could not be stopped he was hitting
him at will
uh
like this is like that's that's how he
always looks in front of any opponent
every almost all the opponents that he
fights
he's just like
it's like a
white kid he's like a black kid playing
basketball
in front of a bunch of white people
uh he's like uh he's like really uh
he's like really out of the everyone's
league that's what it makes that's what
he makes other people look like
um
he's just like juking and driving like
they can't keep up they're like
and then you see them just like what's
happening what's gonna happen next i
don't know he's just too fast
uh he's good at hiding his movements
honestly
i don't know why you guys uh
wouldn't want to hear my thoughts on the
ufc but this is what i think
so i'll just say it
i hope that i'm not making myself look
like an idiot because honestly i i don't
play ufc i don't play mma
anymore i used to a little bit but uh
yeah i mean if you don't do it then you
don't really know what you're talking
about and i don't do it so i don't
really know what i'm talking about but
hey it's fun to talk [ __ ] right it's fun
to act like uh
i'm not an idiot
so ryan hall and derek derrick minor was
the other fight i saw
and uh ryan hall
threatened the legs but derek minor got
out of it all the time
uh ryan hall was obviously really good
on the ground but derek minor never got
submitted derek minor he did this thing
where he just kept going at him in the
grappling exchange and it's like why are
you doing that stay on your feet it's
like an ego thing i think derrick miner
is a wrestler that's what they were
saying in the commentary
and uh he doesn't want he wants to beat
ryan hall at his own game but don't beat
him at his own game beat him in the
sport of mma
uh don't go down on the ground with him
if that's his specialty you beat him by
making him play your game but you beat
him in mma
uh that's what you're doing you're not
like trying to defeat him and take away
his soul and crush his testicles and
make his children cry
beat him and win the money and
i don't know it's just frustrating to
watch
because uh he looked like he was getting
the better of him on the feet
and then he just kept going to the
ground with him because he was like i
can defeat you on the ground too [ __ ]
and he couldn't
um but ryan hall's amazing on the ground
such a fun fighter to watch he's so
different his uh [ __ ]
kicks are getting better they're
dangerous as [ __ ] and he's slow as [ __ ]
so you don't see it coming he's just
standing there and all of a sudden he
like whips his leg out and does like
spinning back kicks or whatever he just
he perfects like one or two strikes and
then he just spams it
uh
which is such a nerdy he's like a nerd
that learned how to fight and he's just
like trying to figure out how to kill
these jocks
and as a nerd i love seeing that i love
seeing intelligence beat out
um jockish energy um
i love ryan hall on the ground he's so
creative he's not in danger in any
position he can spin around and squirrel
around i would like to see him be a
little more vicious i think he's a
little too nice
i think like he rolls with too many
training partners as i'm talking out of
my ass but he doesn't want to hurt
people it seems like
uh he's too nice and i think that he
needs to like when he's like mounted
someone or has someone's back he needs
to [ __ ] elbow the [ __ ] out of their
head
he needs to like [ __ ] him up and like
make him
weep and make their children cry
i don't think he has enough of that in
him
yet
uh and maybe he doesn't need it like
it'd be impressive if he could become
the champion and get on top of the ufc
by not hurting anyone like the peaceful
ufc fighter who never had to hurt anyone
he's such a nice little guy who
who got who defeated everyone physically
uh but didn't leave a scratch on them i
think that'd be hilarious
just like uh
hey guys i know i thought i'm the
champion i want everyone just to be nice
to each other
after you strike someone i want you to
say three nice things about them and i
think like he could make the ufc like a
nicer place i guess which would be nice
um did i see louise new special no not
yet i want to i'm excited about it
um
i think it'd be fun to watch
i honestly i'm not that big of special
uh
a fan of louie
um
thanks hans kim i just won a halo
tournament match while listening to you
see that's the kind of uh winners that
are in my chat our halo tournament
winners match tournament match winners
so i'm glad that i could uh distract you
while you were trying to do something i
imagine if you were totally
concentrating
on the halo then you'd probably be even
better
[Music]
why does evil prevail on earth
on his evil profile on
um because most people are afraid of uh
most people are afraid of dying and they
would rather not die so they let evil
persist so that they can continue to
live
um
i'm not in the van i'm in my friend's
house that i'm house sitting for i'm
always away on vacation curtis i have
three houses right now the van rachel
rachel's apartment and curtis is a house
now so it's uh i went from no home to
two homes so
uh in some ways i'm more home to than
most of you
um since youtube isn't showing dislikes
anymore shop is going to drop his next
special there
i mean shav is a very uh controversial
figure but i think that uh he's a meat
head and people love to [ __ ] on meat
heads but you know i think he can take
it i think he's a great great uh
we need all types we don't just need
ryan hall we also need brendan shabby
straight up murderer at the comedy store
peace from the middle east
keep your peace dude you need it there
we got enough peace here
until
um
[Music]
until the next riots happen
i want to watch the new louis special i
will if it's free i don't pay for media
it's just this thing that i do
uh
i try to get everything for free i think
i'm entitled to it i'm a spoiled
millennial
it's my way of
fighting the uh whatever
but i do want to watch it just because
he's a lot of people's favorite comedian
and i respect their opinion i just don't
really like him myself because i think
that he is uh
he's like
uh i think he puts too much
stink on the setups where he like
is like
and it's just like i don't know it makes
me feel gross watching it feels very
self-indulgent sometimes
um
yeah i know it's a ten dollar
self-produced special but i ain't paying
it but i'll try to watch it
i mean at least i'm watching it would
you rather have me not pay a not watch
or not pay and watch at least if i watch
then i am imparted with your wisdom and
your words and i can go around spreading
the whatever
spreading the ideas that you had
um
let me see k made me laugh harder
um i just feel like he's like too
comfortable being gross i wish that he
would try harder to not be so gross but
i think that he's great at what he does
and a lot of people love that part of
him because that's speaks to a lot of
people
uh it's just like not my
type of comedy and it's not like i hate
him it's like because everyone loves him
so much the fact that i don't
grovel at his feet is like
interesting to me that uh i don't really
think of him the same way as other
people but i'm sure it's just a taste
thing because like people that love him
[ __ ] love the [ __ ] out of him
um
i think that
him getting cancelled during the metoo
thing was ridiculous i think the me too
movement had a lot of negative energy
attached to it
and i think that women think that they
can just be as shitty as they want
because they're so beautiful and
i think that uh it's
uh not the best
mentality to just love your gender
because your gender is not something you
can control
and it's not something that you worked
on
and if you find your identity and your
gender i think you're going to be a very
shallow dumb person because it's just
mostly hormones and genitals i think
that there should be more
than just
just your basic instincts and your
genetics i think what you can make of
yourself is better than your genetics
and you shouldn't celebrate your
genetics and your gender
i think that there should be more
um sorry that i hate the metoo movement
and thus
i hate women but that's just how i feel
greetings from sydney australia thank
you leon
uh thank you for the australian 10 bucks
i hope that you can
save some money so that you can fight
your lockdown protest in australia those
look pretty crazy
in celery
says secondhand sampler
um
i don't like louis c.k either
yeah i mean i like to make fun of race
but race is cool because it makes you uh
fall in line with people that think like
you and everyone decides to think the
same way
uh
i mean it's australian ten dollars and
youtube takes like thirty percent or
something ridiculous so that's why i
always suggest venmo but it's just like
an extra step people like being able to
just press that button and give and i'm
you know thank you i appreciate anything
from anyone really
what's a conspiracy theory you believe
is true i think the cia killed
john f kennedy i think uh the powers
that be killed john f kennedy because he
was going to make the world a better
place
whose house did you break into curtis's
house he's going to be the new general
manager or something at the new rogan
club
so you know i'm staying in this house
and i hope that i can stay in the club
when it opens up maybe i can live there
that would actually be awesome but no
i'm kidding of course i want to want to
live at joe rogan's new club because
then that would make the whole place
feel gross like oh someone lives here i
wouldn't want my presents and my stinky
asian armpits to stink up the new
beautiful shining jewel
in the uh
artistic scene of uh
this new art scene that joe rogan is
creating so i'm just kidding but if i
could that'd be [ __ ] dope
oh there there's the dog you see the dog
he's over there
wherein is the rogan club going to e
completed
probably when you learn to
not
spell incorrectly
it was jackie oh jackie who killed
kennedy
she did a behind the back she's
on tape too which is impressive
probably won't let koreans in his new
club joe rogan loves korean he's a
taekwondo champion taekwondo
can you give us a [ __ ] tour of that
refrigerator i don't want to give it to
her a house that's not mine
uh were you ever worried about std when
making out with all those women what std
mono
i mean herpes is not if you can see it
coming and also
everyone already has it or whatever
uh but i mean i guess herpes is the
worst one but it's not like that big a
deal
[Music]
no honestly i think most people are
clean and that
you shouldn't tell yourself that people
are gross
because that's a bad way to look at
people and it prevents you from making
out with them furiously on live youtube
so i love the [ __ ] kisses and i think
that it's great that we can
celebrate kissing and love each other
and i think we should do more of that
are you able to see dislikes still on
your end i can see percentages i think
i don't know i haven't really sought it
out i don't like to look at those
numbers too much even though i do watch
it too much
um
kyotoni will move to that new club i
think i honestly don't know
like the guy gal you look up to if heat
rises why does the sun set because the
earth is rotating
and there is no up or down in space is
there a dish that you think you kick the
best
ribs
someone redacted a message please if
someone redacts a message
re-message that because i want to see
and run pooch freezing what's the point
of swinging weed while someone is high
on acid
um maybe you want to join them in
highness or
maybe uh i don't know
i don't know just because someone's on
acid doesn't mean i hate doesn't mean i
love sobriety
do you know what made me so wise um
probably being 32
and also
not
uh
not
putting any of my intellect in the
existing infrastructure
the existing intellectual infrastructure
in our society is there to distract you
to compromise you religion
is there to compromise you
intellectually to make your conscious
mind more like your subconscious mind
um you know school is there to [ __ ] up
your brain
um are your thoughts on ufo uap uap i
don't know about uap
why don't you why don't i ap
um
but yeah i mean i i would say just like
not
going down the grooved paths of
intellectual pursuits that exist in our
society because i think a lot of that is
corrupt
you do have to use some
paths i would say joe rogan has really
helped me think
and look at the world in a different
light i i love the way that he has a
penchant for the truth and he can feel
it out
okay if redman says kt is moving to the
new club then uh
i believe him
i think i still have coveted brain oh
that's too bad i mean
i've done so much crazy drugs and
gone into so many head bangers in my
life that covet is the least of my
concern
uh probably like all the ass that i did
is probably having a bigger impact on my
brain right now but uh yeah i mean if i
could do all that [ __ ] covets not that
big a deal i mean it is a thing but you
know i've had bad trips before you just
gotta wheel yourself out of it just
start hucking
get all that blood out of your head tell
us your latest conquest since this video
used
[ __ ]
use the kissing screenshot
oh
last monday was quite a monday for me
uh so after the show i went up to the
patio and there was a couple that had
gone on kill tony that day that comes
out in two weeks
and
they had both gone on separately the
woman was there the man was there the
man said nice things to me the woman was
also said nice things to me and then i
was like hey can i make out with you
it's kind of my thing i kind of make out
with people and i kind of want to do it
with you no offense man we want to
record it and then he was like yeah i'll
record hans kim making out with my
girlfriend and so then i passionately
made out with this dude's girlfriend in
a very sexual way and then he's like all
right all right and then he ended it and
then i was like why don't you guys kiss
and i'll record you
now i have a video on my phone of a
couple kissing so i don't really know
what to do with that i should send it to
them because i know them on uh
instagram
but uh and then uh later in the night i
met the montgomery sisters who are these
two redheads that sat in the front row
of the show
and then i was talking with them we were
vibing we were chatting and then
they were like let's take a picture
let's take a picture
and then i had them on either side of me
and then i was like oh it's like kind of
my thing like i like kiss people you
want to do this little kissing thing
and then i uh kissed one and then i
kissed the other
and then later that night
this girl i had talked to earlier at the
bar
at the kill tony was like what are you
doing i'm gonna come over here and i was
like i'm here you should come over
here's the dress
and then she came over
and then i touched her butt
and then i tried to kiss her and then
she pushed me away and she's like you're
being so naughty
and then we went to the kitchen i
touched her butt some more
um
and then we sat down and then i touched
her leg and then i touched her [ __ ]
and she was like stop you're being so
naughty and then we just held hands and
i put my hand on her thigh and then i
held hands and then
she went to leave and i touched her butt
some more
and then i kissed her
but then she was like a little kiss [ __ ]
stop
kind of kiss so
um and then i walked her out
grabbed her butt and kissed her some
more
those pecking kisses
and that was my night so no sexual
thing but you know it was pretty sexual
the kisses
so you know i had fun uh
is the the best i could have done
without having uh
put my dick into anything so you know
sometimes it's like fun to uh
sometimes it's fun to uh just
i don't know what i was gonna say uh
hans is definitely gonna
hit sued
yeah i mean whatever i don't care it was
all consensual and i think this over
obsession with consensuality is just an
american obsession with individuality
and like what we really want changes
and is fluid depending on the situation
and i didn't do anything that would be a
crime
uh and if you think so then uh i feel
bad for you and this is probably why we
have less sex than any other generation
is because we respect individual liberty
too much
and i would love to have some of my
individual liberty taken away
so that i could [ __ ]
um yeah i mean if you want to over
legislate every part of the human
experience then
you're going to [ __ ] yourself so
go ahead and do that to me but you're
only shooting yourself in the foot not
everything is consensual or whatever
cody steffik the hans kim militia is
growing with each sunrise and nightfall
you have blessed us with as general i
urge others to donate or spread the word
of our leader with our local community
hail hans
it makes me feel like i'm like a cobra
commander
yeah like william montgomery about guns
guns i got two guns
i'm gonna get some tissue
i mean the best part of
um
the best part of being a human is like
being with other people and not being
yourself but being something larger than
yourself and i think if you're always
just trying to be yourself then you can
never
transcend yourself and be better than
yourself and that's sad that you always
have to be stuck in your shitty little
brain in your shitty little
mind
uh
yeah so i think that uh it's like such a
shitty way to be like no what i say is
the law and if you disobey me then
you're going to jail i think that's like
really
toxic mentality and i think that we
should be able to be a part of something
larger than ourselves and uh not just be
focused on
our preconceived ideas of who we are but
be able to change and adapt to the
situation
and i think a lot of people can't do
that and i think a lot of americans are
incapable of being a part of something
larger than themselves
and that
they are not good to be in relationships
with because they only think about
themselves and about their journey and
are incapable of thinking about your
journey or our journey
so uh yeah
it's a bit of a problem
our society we have reached the end of
individualism and we are decaying
individualism is a false goal
oh well who hurt you i don't know check
out all the kill tonys
how do you think psychedelics has
changed your perspective on life what do
you think you would be missing out on if
you never did psychedelics again
the good thing about psychedelics is
that if you don't do any drugs you're
just on this one brain state if you do
psychedelics then you're in this other
brain state and then you can observe
your brain state from another point of
view and the more psychedelics you do
and the more experiences you have i mean
it doesn't have to be psychedelics it
can just be life experiences but the
more
uh different states of mind that you can
occupy the more that you can inform your
sober state of mind
and other different you can
adopt other states of mind
and if you're going to adopt other
states of mind then you can choose the
state of mind that you find most
beneficial to your life instead of just
adopting a state of mind that you happen
to be born in and it's easier to observe
what's going on and to criticize
uh things about yourself if you're not
so invested and
you know taking your one state of mind
as yours and that nothing can change it
so that's what i think is great about
that
the last other people episode there was
no sound in i think the zoom h6 wasn't
plugged in all the way and the sound
only two mics were picking up the other
two wasn't
hey hans hitler or mao yeah i mean if
you think that i am
like a mass murderer i mean
i don't know what to tell you that's
that's pretty easy to avoid in my
opinion
is to not be a terrible terrible person
i think that what's harder to avoid is a
coup
by the us government
staged in your home country
so i think the best thing about
psychedelics is that it let me
uh
criticize my state of being and my mind
and so improve because now i'm not
invested in that state of mind that's
not who i am that's just who i am when
i'm sober that's who i am when i'm
bored and now i can adopt other states
of mind
i haven't governed
so i have no idea what i would do
i might become a murderer and kill a
bunch of people
i mean if you're in charge of the
country you're gonna kill people like
even obama kill people
biden's killing people
bush definitely killed people trump
definitely killed people it's like uh
you gotta break a couple legs if you
decide hey we're gonna build a couple
housing projects over here you're gonna
kill like maybe a construction worker
maybe like someone whose uh
house was there is gonna be killed
because then now they have to move and
they get really sad and they die of
depression but then you're gonna save 70
lives so it's all like uh
a game and then like you just have to
make sure that the
pros outweigh the cons but then like
sometimes people get a little
uh free-form jazz with that kind of
calculations and they're like well these
people don't need any food they were not
nice to me and if you're not nice to me
then this whole thing falls apart so
i would just treat it like simcity and
not have so much ego about it like
stalin did i'll just be like how do you
make the best country i don't want to
[ __ ] you know whatever let's just
[ __ ] get everything working let's get
the ports open let's have no traffic
let's have like you know just so i can
figure it out i don't know i don't i
don't think it's that hard to uh
run a country i think uh
it's all that old [ __ ]
all that king and queen and billionaire
[ __ ]
uh that everyone was playing in the past
and i think we have a more aware and
psychedelically influenced population
now
and i think we can do a lot better than
those old [ __ ] farts who were just
coming out of the industrial revolution
those cavemen
um but uh yeah i mean that's a lot of
confidence to have so maybe uh
i uh yeah i don't know it's probably
until i get there i can't really do
anything but speculate so i don't know
what you want me to do
x equals six y equals five i think it
was x equals five y equals six
yeah i'm pretty sure
i'm sure you got it backwards
um
how did i date pre-kill tony i went to
open mics and comedy shows
and try to [ __ ] people that thought i
was funny
um
i think that there's not enough sex
happening and i think that it's like so
[ __ ] up that everyone
uh thinks that sex is gross and that
they're better than everyone else and
they don't [ __ ] anyone because they
think that it's like whatever
huh you're the definition of a caveman
you can only say old people bad
i mean that's not what caveman said
caveman said
groot is kind
um i mean
i wish i could say old people not bad
but then you look at history and their
track record and it's not that great i'm
not judging them for being old i'm
judging them for their actions which we
can observe
yeah i mean in
city skylines you can
play with traffic and get get it to be
better so how many cia agents do you
think you have probably zero the system
is very good at neutralizing threats
they do it
with lots of different methods mostly
economic
and financial
and by making you have kids early so
that you can't do anything with your
life
you had a great call back i just don't
think that
the numbers were right but yeah the idea
was there so like i'm talking about
something political and complicated and
you're like basically x equals six or x
equals five and y equals six
i don't know history
well that's a bummer i thought i did
you're not into sex
i wish i was into sex
yeah it'd be the fbi i don't know if the
fbi has any agents on me um why would
you need an agent i guess just to watch
the youtube videos of me talking about
getting pegged
how does one have thick skin
um don't be an old white woman
i lost way too many hours to city
skylines i wish i could play i don't
know how to do it
um
how does being on kill tony get you laid
a bunch i mean it got me laid
a decent amount
um but so far no takers let me check
yep no one wants to [ __ ] me
it's crazy because if anyone wanted to
[ __ ] me they could they just don't
they just don't
and i think that just comes down to uh
you know they don't want to [ __ ]
a lot of people don't want to [ __ ]
uh they are too
traumatized it's too fragile they're too
fragile they don't want to risk anything
by [ __ ]
is the background green screen no this
is a real kitchen
this is my friend curtis's house who's
gonna be the new general manager at the
the new rogan club
do what buffalo bob did so one together
from rotund women
i'm not a seamstress i
don't want to
have a decaying corpse in my house i
would rather be alone
uh that's what's so awesome is that
being alone is so fun
and
it's just great if you love being alone
then you'll never hurt anyone i don't
care about people enough to
uh sew them together
i uh i wish i could
enough that i would sacrifice my sanity
and my
morality and go out on sixth street or a
bar and just try to talk to people and
get my feelings hurt and go out there
again and talk to idiots who don't
really respect me or know me
but
i don't
i don't want to do that i don't want to
take a
take that risk of my sanity and my
self-esteem to go out and talk to people
um but
yeah maybe like i think i'm better than
people and so i don't [ __ ] them but
honestly i would [ __ ] a lot of people i
just don't want to go through the
process of
talking to the idiots who are going to
be hurtful because
they think they have a right to be
vicious and mean because
i'm trying to take sex away from them
and sex is a precious resource that you
have to use to make money in capitalist
america
a fox really hates me you are an
emotional vampire
well unfortunately i can't be invited in
unless you invite me in so
if you invite me in then i will
do whatever i have to do
to feel good while i'm inside your house
is elon musk lying about how declining
birth rates will be humanity's undoing
so our government will lower the age of
consent i don't think that lowering the
age of consent will help us [ __ ] more
there's plenty of [ __ ] people we
don't have to [ __ ] children there's
plenty of adults
that can we can [ __ ]
uh
so i think that uh
i think that uh the real problem is uh
wealth inequality and that the problem
isn't that we're not [ __ ] enough
children
uh i think that elon musk
needs to spread the wealth that he is
not that inventive that there are real
inventors who need that money
um
it's already 15
do you think it matters where you live
to be successful in comedy yes it
matters very much where you live uh it
matters how much money you have
it makes
it it matters who your parents are uh
what your financial situation is what
your family situation is all that
matters
i was born into a rich family
i had a lot of free time i didn't have
any kids because i was
roundly rejected by fertile females
i had uh
not too many distractions
and i had access to open mics so i did a
lot of comedy and then i moved to new
york to do even more
um
i i just love uh
what is love
you're doing everything
um
so
um
hans is greater than hitler aphromet has
a song about it come to thailand i would
love to
do i own bitcoin no i think it's a ponzi
scheme um i think that we should
actually use bitcoin instead of just
speculating on it
go to bed it's 9 21. i have a show at
11. i'm not a [ __ ]
uh office worker i have a
nocturnal schedule
my time in mechanical engineering can be
described as fruitful and
vociferous and luxurious
my time in mechanical engineering was uh
i did a lot of school i learned
equations how to apply it when to apply
this equation over that equation how to
use that equation and how to find the
derivative of whatever
and uh it was really interesting i
really enjoyed it because um
i don't know i just i'm interested in
that kind of [ __ ] about how the world
works and how you can describe [ __ ] with
equations i think that's
awesome and then you go to
get a job in mechanical engineering and
it's nothing
of that sort it's not equations all that
[ __ ] is in a computer anyways uh most of
it is like managing workers i think or
doing autocad i actually don't know
because i didn't get a job in it but
it's not a lifestyle that i wanted i
didn't want to sit in an office all day
and make caterpillar or
john deere more money
[Music]
i didn't want to live a life as a
cubicle worker i wanted to be a comedian
or a rock star
and as an ugly man the only rock star
status available is as a comedian or
like i don't know like a dj
so
yeah
so then i i uh so i did school for four
years i got suspended for one semester
for shoplifting at a target
and then i finished in four years even
though i did math for my first year and
then i switched to majors so i had a lot
of extracurricular activities to do
um
and then um
and then i got a job as an intern
uh getting paid minimum wage at
grenzebuch
which makes roller conveyors that are
then used to make solar panels and glass
so i was making roller
puller conveyors
they really didn't assign me much of
work
um
i guess they didn't trust me or anything
they didn't really give me a chance i
was falling asleep on the first day
because i had just flown in the day
before and i guess it was just a wrong
message that's the thing i hate about
jobs it's all about like [ __ ]
perception and like what they think of
you because then the guy that got the
internship after me said that he was
busy he had a lot of work it's like i
was able to do they didn't even give me
a chance they didn't give me a shot
uh so i was like you know [ __ ] you guys
uh
i i don't want to play this game or i
have to like pretend like i'm like
some sort of person just give me a
chance let me see if i can do the work i
don't want to do it the way that you do
it let me do it the way that i do it and
if i do good work then that should be
all that matters but it's not about that
it's about like
showing that
you think the same or something
um
i just got the lineup
there was a shootout
at the theater i was watching spider-man
at it says my friend gareth
welcome to america
um i mean i think the shootout is a
is a uh
symptom of like
we don't own anything in our society
millennials have five percent of the gdp
um
i think that
i think that
[Music]
since we don't own anything we want to
we resort to
sorry
uh so because we don't own anything we
the only thing we can do is threaten
each other and have uh
and uh own people
that's what mobsters are they're just
using the resource that is people
because if you don't have any other
resources you're stuck with people so
these are just like gang members
fighting over turf or perceived insults
trying to
use the resource of people
and
i think that if we owned more of the
economy if these people were like
a part of a
you know the sewage
or trash collectors or doing some
meaningful work and making an impact in
society they want to feel the need to uh
make
um
make an effort in uh
[ __ ] people up and you know i just
think it's
we don't have a purpose so we [ __ ]
shoot each other to
[ __ ] each other up because that's more
of a purpose than going to mcdonald's
and doing nothing in it being like a
cheaper version of a robot
uh so i
i think that we need to be given more of
the economy or else we will resort to
violence and it's not a threat it's
an observation it's what people do if we
don't have our purpose we make our own
i'm not tripping
[Music]
i think this is the uh
it's the inevitable conclusion of
not giving people
a seat at the table of the economy
what is your favorite non-korean asian
food probably
hey fox you're about to get banned
uh
what's your favorite non-korean asian
food probably
uh
general sews or something
like you're on basalts you're not making
sense you don't think that uh
we don't okay
bath salts are uppers
yeah i'm definitely not an uppers
i mean i don't think that we own enough
of the economy to
uh
to
uh
incentivize us to work better to be good
people if you're not if you're giving us
five percent of the gdp what are we
gonna do we're just if if you make
everyone
uh if
if you just make everyone um
work at mcdonald's
then what are we supposed to do we're
just supposed to be happy with that
we're just supposed to be happy going to
a cubicle doing nothing wasting our time
browsing reddit all day
uh you know
uh it's just like
it's like not enough
you you
we can't be satisfied with that the
human mind the human spirit longs for
more than just menial labor and if
that's all you give us we'll find our
own meaning
um
and you know like we aren't given enough
of the economy the economy is held back
from us and
we can't get more of it through the
means
that are legal or approved of
so
if you if you leave us no choice
then we will
try
to we will try to
get it through any means necessary
i mean think about your friends
and all the jobs that they do
and all the people that you know that
are 20 and 30 years old they're doing
nothing they're [ __ ] delivery drivers
they're waiters
this is not them being lazy this is not
them being stupid this is just the
choices this is what
we have available for us
um we can change the levers in society
and make a better society and make one
that
gives us options to be better people and
have better jobs um
people can work hard working hard is
easy
choosing what you work hard at is where
you should actually spend more of your
energy thinking about
um
i don't think that my friends who work
in the service industry which is like
pretty much all of them
or who have cubicle jobs uh
is are lazy or stupid i think that
they're not given the right choices and
if everyone is [ __ ] up and making the
wrong choices it's not everyone's fault
it's the choices that they're presented
with they're doing the best they can
they're rational actors in society so we
need to change the uh
the numbers and the choices that they're
given
and uh we don't have a free
society we don't have a society that
emphasizes and exaggerates
and uh highlights and
utilizes our potential to our fullest we
have a society that actively tries to
make us less than we are
um
i am a baseball umpire by choice i'm
glad that you're doing that i hope that
other people can also make that choice
and judging by the numbers uh they
aren't doing that
okay hans this is so boring that i'm
actually getting the comedic effect now
this is hilarious
okay dude
uh if it's boring i don't really care i
don't respect your intellect or your
taste
so um i'm sorry that this is boring to
you but
i am having a blast
people just need to stop saying that
they can't you turn off your brain with
that word i'm not saying i can't i'm
saying that i can't through the normal
methods and means that are provided to
us i can
by going outside the system
and
uh
and
and fighting against the way things are
right now but you want to fight within
the system you want to just do whatever
is
uh already laid out and i think that's
boring i don't think that works
i don't think that just being really
good at being a cubicle worker is uh
is an ability that is impressive
or it will yield results
i think that uh
like just being like just work within
the system just work really hard at
mcdonald's you know soon you'll own a
mcdonald's how many mcdonald's owners do
you know worked their way into that or
uh
have uh
got that
resources or capital because
they were really good at being a burger
flipper they got it because their family
already had money or
they got it through some other means
and then they're getting [ __ ] by
mcdonald's
so uh i uh
i don't think that saying that the
system is [ __ ] is defeatist i think
judging emotions
and being like oh you should always
think positively i think that's how you
get [ __ ]
oh the guy that the guy that owned that
that's your boss
he's always gonna you can't you can't
change that just don't change the top
just change what you do i think instead
we should uh
uh i think that instead we should fight
the system and create a better one and
replace it instead of just being lazy
and leaving the system as it is i think
it's lazy to not work hard to change the
world that we were given it's easy to
just be like this is the way it is just
work within it don't change anything
about it i think it's hard to change it
and i'm willing to do that hard work i
would work my ass off to change the
system i would do zero work to help this
system continue
and i haven't had a job in forever
because i don't want to be a part of
this
how should we as a society create better
options for younger people uh
emphasizing their talents making sure
that they're not just sitting in class
taking notes and reading and watching
other people do [ __ ]
um
uh
i think uh by
if someone shows an interest in violin
hey you don't have to [ __ ] you know
learn uh all the other [ __ ] you can
just focus on that here's some great
violin players to hang out with uh if
you find an interest in uh plumbing or
you know working with your hands you
should be
taught that and you should be emphasized
that
when in history were there better
options for young people um
probably in hunter-gatherer times
probably other types
um
i don't know i i know in korea there was
a lot of like taking the civil exam that
was a big thing it's [ __ ] but
i uh i think that
like in medieval ages if you were good
at farming you could be a farmer if you
were good at blacksmithing you could be
a blacksmith
right now people just [ __ ] your [ __ ] up
and make you do [ __ ]
work yeah i'm still playing within the
system by living in a van and doing
comedy this this isn't the system
i've done as much as i could to be out
of the system
i think that uh
it's idiotic to just be like this is the
way it is
don't change it just work really hard
like a cattle like [ __ ]
a cow i think it's much more difficult
to change the whole world and i think
you are lazy if you don't want to do
that i think you are scared
and you just want to live a nice
pleasant hedonistic life and that is not
our lot in life
we're millennials even if we play by the
rules we're going to live in an
apartment forever so if that's the other
side like who gives a [ __ ]
let's [ __ ] do something with their
lives it's better to uh you know
go out as a warrior then live your whole
life as a [ __ ] peasant
but that's just me
and i know that a lot of you are too
scared to do anything
about the world that you live in
no one can change the world yeah why
don't you tell that to martin luther
king jr or the french revolution or
world war ii or hitler or
obama
we are the only people that can change
the world we exist right now the only
people that exist in uh
physical reality right now are us and we
have the power
to change we can move this brick from
here to there we can move this [ __ ]
truck from there to here we have the
power and no one else can do it for us
because they don't exist
uh
what you say bounces off me and sticks
onto you god damn it
how did you do that dude you [ __ ] got
me
um but yeah i mean uh why not have a
revolution you're afraid that you'll die
i mean who gives a [ __ ]
i mean that's the thing it's like if
we're all like only focused on our
individual lives and and you're only
worried about like making the best for
yourself then obviously it makes no
sense to have a revolution
but i think that if you're looking at
the larger picture and you want
something better for the human race
then your life becomes very easy to
sacrifice and i don't think that's a
very good answer either
but i don't think that complacency
and
you know malaise is good and i think
that's what we're plagued with more than
the
desire to change the world
at whatever sacrifice it takes for me
but yeah i obviously don't want to die
for the cause
i if i was presented with that option i
don't know what i'd choose
but you know who knows are you prominent
to return to monk philosophy do you
believe in moral relativism um i don't
really know what those words mean
monk philosophy moral relativism i think
morality is pretty uh
innate
i think we should just figure it out on
our own eating off the government cheese
yes communism is available you just have
to go out and take it
i think the burn it on down mentality is
dangerous obviously we don't have to
burn it all down but why is any change
or improvement in the system classified
as burn it all down
um
so yeah i mean uh one of my favorite
books is sex at dawn
another one of my favorite books
uh sex at dawn is all about how people
back in the hunter-gatherer days were
better than us because they were
healthier and they
knew how to do [ __ ] and figure it out
um
so yeah i mean i think it's great that
uh
we're all chilling here
and uh we have like a lot of fun
all the time
i i find that most people i don't like
to talk to at bars and stuff i like to
uh actually do a lot of different things
christopher ryan
i think it's just better to be uh
better to be in another place
don't be so sure your plan will work out
i think that uh
we need to change the system and uh we
could be self-conscious about it but uh
i'd like to change it i don't think uh
not changing it is good i don't think
just like keeping it the way it is is
the best
so i'm on the show
at 11
it's 9 40 right now i probably should
leave at 10
10 30. so like a couple more minutes
you can find people at bars have deep
conversations with
a few and fart between though exactly i
totally agree with you and it's like i'd
rather have deep relationships and a lot
of shallow ones do you deal with a lot
of racism nope not really i don't think
so i deal with more class struggles and
racism
this is not a van this is my friend
curtis's house he's letting me stay here
while he's on vacation i have access to
two houses now in one van
if more than half our society was
disciplined and striving for a healthy
lifestyle do you think that would change
the system considering the system is
built to keep us dead inside yeah i
think that if we all [ __ ] got it
together and became amazing people
it would be useless because our system
is designed to not find any use in
people and to preserve the existing
wealth structure
smoking a blunt for you hans stay high
my man thanks bruins
that's so nice
i would love to smoke a bun lund i miss
deep conversation people want the bar
hard to come by these days yeah
um i mean it's so politically charged
everyone has their beliefs and stuff
so
i like seoul i think that he's secretly
a uh
neocon
uh i think that he serves the interest
of the powers that be he blames black
people for their problem i don't think
black people are to blame i think that
the people in power are to blame
uh i think that that is uh whatever
later bro see you jonathan hunt the live
chat thing you are doing is what twitch
streamers make a living doing that's
what i'm trying to do
maybe i should do it on twitch but i
don't have an audience there and so it's
like
it's fun to chat with people so i do it
on youtube i don't know how to transfer
this to twitch but if i could i would
because i don't really trust youtube i
don't like youtube
web3 it literally embodies your values
and ethos and is working to change the
financial rails of the world um i don't
want to like sign up for like
a thing
i don't need to have
my ideas be incorporated into another
uh organization i think we just need to
[ __ ] all shout out our opinions and
then
that [ __ ] soup of ideas will
be awesome and then people can figure
out whatever they want to believe
um but i don't know what uh not ignoring
web3 looks like would you ever consider
a celebrity boxing match well first i
have to become a celebrity
but uh boxing match
yeah i mean i'm a human i'm a dumb
animal i would love to physically engage
in combat i don't know if that would be
the best choice
for my head
but maybe a celebrity mma match because
mma is more my speed because it's more
[ __ ] awesome
i have it enough enough today dank
shorts dang shorts is embodying asian
mother energy right now
have you eaten today you look so skinny
have you heard of the passing of the
prolific dj and producer chairs the fist
maybe charles the fifth as a not spoken
in insiduously and secular culture you
should check him out i think you'd enjoy
thank you
hans kim versus ryan katsu riviera i
don't know ryan katsu riviera i hope i'm
bigger than him you should put on a
video of your bjj sparring session
um yeah i don't know if i'm ready to be
that vulnerable to show people what i
look like when i'm rolling around the
ground on a in a pajama with another man
because it shows you a side of my
[ __ ] that i really don't want out
there on the internet but maybe i will
maybe i'll live stream me trying to
choke someone
hans if you're starting in comedy in
austin where would you begin
probably the um
probably the creek and the cave
is where i would begin
um
it's a cool place
it's a nice place
okay
i think i'm done thank you guys so much
and i love you
please have a good night and uh suck on
some clits and or
uh
the
whatever the uh
prostate
prostate or [ __ ]
i see